let's go next to our caller from the 4-1
to area code I think 4 1 2 is Pittsburgh
if I recall correctly caller and 4 1 2
can you hear me what's your name where
are you calling from yes my name is
Brian I am from Pittsburgh right
what's on your mind uh well I wanted to
ask you Dave what do you think of the
concept of anti-natal ISM I'm sorry
antinatalism correct in terms of
opposing birthing to reduce the
birthrate that that's correct okay we'll
talk a little bit more about it how how
would an antenatal is on what grounds
would an antenatal is argue well for
what I mean if we look at the state of
the world as it is today I mean what it
is it really feasible to bring more
children into this world and force them
to endure what I would call excruciating
suffering due to you know we look at the
clathrate gun firing off with the
melting of the permafrost yeah or you
look at the depletion of resources they
can only go downhill from here
yeah listen I think that there's a
couple different thoughts on that and
I've actually thought about this quite a
bit just in terms of like if I wanted to
have a kid someday would I feel okay
saying here's the world we have I'm
going to choose to bring a new person
into it given all of the terrible things
that go on if you have a fundamentally
this to me this sort of come down it
comes down to your long-term view on the
future of Homo sapiens right if your
view is that if we are thoughtful and we
make changes that most of the changes we
already sort of know what they have to
be with regard to energy consumption and
resource usage and pollution and whatnot
if you believe that the project of Homo
sapiens is a worthwhile project then I
think that the thoughtful bringing of
new people onto the planet makes sense
now do I support having six seven eight
kids like many in in religious
communities do I certainly or in Hasidic
Judaism and in other sects of
Christianity I don't I don't
support that but I believe that if you
if you're long if you're bullish long
term on homo sapiens and it's hard to be
when you see you know Trump's president
after all right how could we really be
that bullish on the future of Homo
sapiens but if you are I think that the
thoughtful rearing of children does make
sense so I don't call myself an
anti-natal list but I totally respect
people who say you know what I don't
feel good about bringing children into
the world that we have now and so I'm
going to choose not to I I respect that
I'm not there yet I mean that's
understandable but aren't aren't you
clinging to a more sort of optimism bias
in which you kind of say to yourself
well there's a chance but it seems like
with each passing year the chance to
make the world more livable habitable
and manageable slips away yeah it might
appear that way but remember we are only
observing a very very small slice of
changes so even what we're seeing from
year to year as I agree with you it's
devastating what we're doing to the
planet I don't find that I would be in a
position to really have the 30,000 foot
view on that to say you know what no
more children for anybody because we're
clearly not going to be able to you know
figure out what we're doing to the
climate move to other planets whatever
I'm just not there yet and I you know
tort normally my biases to pessimism
actually after all I was born to a
Jewish family so pessimism comes pretty
naturally but an neuroticism but I still
somehow have somewhat of an optimism on
that yeah okay
thanks so much for the call Brian
appreciate it very very interesting and
depressing topic I might say and on that
note let's take a break I'm kind of
bummed out after last that last call and
we'll do a few audience questions next